bonjour je suis Alain Chabat
quand j'ai tourné mission Cléopâtre il y
a plus de 20 ans les couleurs du film
étaient éclatantes vive chamarais et
puis avec le temps et quelques passages
télé les teintes se sont délavées les
couleurs ont perdu de leur fraîcheur
même avec une installation home cinéma
je ne retrouvais pas les clés digne des
célèbres pyramides d'Egypte le truc
pointu là mais aujourd'hui tout a changé
grâce à ciné boost le dernier né des
laboratoires 4K sa formule enrichie en
oligo-éléments plonge au cœur de la
pellicule d'origine pour lui redonner
tout son éclat et sa jeunesse grâce à
ciné boost mon film a retrouvé toute sa
fraîcheur
Hugo
plus beau ça fait plaisir plus fort
grâce à ciné boost et sa lotion magique
même le son est plus puissant
enveloppant décoiffant
pour fêter les 21 ans et demi de sa
sortie Astérix et Obélix mission
Cléopâtre ressort en salle en version
remastérisée 4K Dolby Atmos
Astérix et Obélix mission Cléopâtre
c'est 5 euros la place même après la
fête du cinéma ça va être car ça va
aller très bien sortie le
5 juillet 203